冬ですねプって冬って何かコーチとはが恋しくなりませんか
ああ売れたい作れたい女の頬に触れたっ今回ですねえっと買おうと思いましたラリマー
でこんなロボットペットとかネットポイペットじゃないものと分かったんですけど今回
もちゃんとしたペットで多分ね今回はこちらですオバケー目シーク観察キットは立つ
日間でこういう
おばけがでてるわけですね卵からかえってビッパの馬券になるとなんでこういうの小
学校の時にやったような気もすることもない気がするんですけどなんかすごい面白かっ
た覚えがあります人肌まではいかないですけど
まあねちょっと
寂しくないじゃんちょっと多少でを寂しくなくなるぞで今回このば警備セット今日から
育てますこれいつでも育てていいのかなぁ関節期間
初夏から秋ハーイ秋だっけっていつだっけって便でも11月て桐明じゃねえこその中で
濃い濃い濃い小分けあさあやったかければいいのか
大丈夫そうですね町11月輪切りアッキーなんてさん大丈夫です大丈夫なんですけども
おばあ権利自体がそんなに長く育つ生き物じゃないらしいですそう機関の製造は見込め
ないと思いますなるほど祖母弟日チャンスねそんな長く生きる生き物じゃないらしい
ですね
卵からかえって大きくなって結婚するんだね卵
うんダウ
あーやりましょう大丈夫ってこのガイドブックにうわぁ
オスメスもあるみたいですねなんでこういう育てで系好きなんですよねおば k 1は
えっと円弧
がなんかエロいね返納含んだ水鼻煙壺に住むエビの仲間でい目から約5億年も前からい
た政府ですやばいな
可愛いかわいい a 可愛い可愛い言ってるん今やイラストを見るとなんか愛着が湧い
ちゃうよねこれなんかを何か着いたと言ってるんですかね店1週間がエサあげなくても
大丈夫みたいです開きますけど範囲ですねこういう
イラスト見たらなんかよしよしってしたくなりますねうふ
ひとまず準備しますまあコレですねまずはこれを水で洗っていきます
水で洗ってきましたここからですねまず足をつけます
えっ
2番目の星までまず水を入れます
[音楽]
しょっ系こちらの海の水の素を入れますああああああわあ
ねぇこれ大丈夫めっちゃに凝ったんだけど次にこれを割り出しなのでよくかき混ぜます
でこの後すぐ卵を入れたいところなんですけど多分1日待ちます一日待って多分カルキ
抜きしなきゃだめなので明治の時間後に会おう
さあっ
東骨に配置日経ちましたどうでしょ昨日と比べて透明度が全然強いますねたぶんこれ
大丈夫なはずだと思いますこれいつも思うんですけど王命だと見にくい中対処小さい
からわかんないからなんか頑張って黒くします背景よ
多分これ貼り付ければなんとかなるでしょ宮瀬いいんじゃない見やすい所
多分拝原黒くしたんでこれでだいぶ観察しやすくなったと思います点差
では卵を入れていこうともう良き徳利だけ入れるんだ
一振りでいいドーン結構たくさん入ってるように見えるんですけど一振りでいいらしい
です一振りでいいんだって事は何回を育てるって事か
じゃあさっそく卵を入れていきましょう1クリだけ入れますよせーのっ
えっ
ok もう入った開いたタブ入ったため入った
細葉山町徳大丈夫からこの水面に浮いてる黒い点々が卵です
こんなに少なくていうのを浮いてるんだけど浮いちゃうよーこの間違いないあってるよ
ね
ねこれ大丈夫大丈夫ならこれ大丈夫だろこれ大丈夫だろって大丈夫へ来たでしょうかん
だけどちょっと今回は3度育てたいと思ってるんでちょっと説明書を見てつ完璧に今回
使っていると思いますでポイントとしてよね
直射に
だれ直射日光を当ててはいけませんよ30度超えると大葉警備が死んでしまうことが
あります
で1日から3日間くらい経つと小さなば警備が生まれてくるらしいです
つまりすぐには生まれないわけですねも明日以降のいつか帰ると思うんですけども
ちっちゃな子供たちが見えたら次は餌を与えると
ok ok 了解しました次の時は
どうば警備が成長した世界だと思いますまいつになるかちょっとわからないんですけど
なるべく成長するために動画とっていこうと思うので皆さん
楽しみにしてるんだぜじゃあ
dee
いい
[音楽]
ん
んでっ